dans cette classe de petite et moyenne
sections de la celle les bordes on
apprend à compter à faire de la musique
ou encore à faire des constructions sans
être perturbés par la présence de jean
michel blanquer
avec ce déplacement le ministre de
l'éducation nationale a voulu montrer le
caractère majeur de l'école maternelle
une mesure qu'il défend dans le projet
de loi sur l'école de la confiance
adopté en février dernier en première
lecture par l'assemblée nationale par
les d'instruction obligatoire à 3 ans
c'est tout simplement dire que oui
l'école commence à trois ans et que les
premières années il faut les prendre
très au sérieux il faut y aller il faut
certes le faire au travers de jeux de
musique de chose qui corresponde à cette
école de la confiance dont je parle
souvent cette école compte 87 élèves de
la petite section au cm2 et joue un rôle
clé dans ce territoire rural des
yvelines c'est ce qu'a voulu réaffirmer
l'équipe enseignante lors d'une table
ronde
ici on est une famille que ce soit les
parents les enseignants la municipalité
tout le monde travaille ensemble on se
connaît tous et c'est vraiment quelque
chose de très important dans le cadre de
la semaine des mathématiques jean michel
blanquer a également voulu souligner
l'importance de cette matière à l'école
et ce dès le plus jeune âge ici s'est
retrouvé à une petite bille dans le
dans le sac est nommé le nombre et après
retrouver le maillot qui est accroché et
qui face cachée quand tous les maillots
sont retournés celui qui a le plus du be
a gagné un exercice ludique qui
visiblement plaît aux enfants avec 7 aux
écoles de la confiance et sa mesure
phare l'instruction obligatoire dès 3
ans le ministre de l'éducation nationale
a réaffirmé sa volonté de lutter contre
les inégalités sociales